we've done a lot of stories lately about
Russian people dying under strange and
suspicious circumstances people whose
deaths might benefit the Kremlin people
who were dissident voices against the
Putin regime I told you about Russia's
UN ambassador Vitaly Churkin who died
suddenly in his New York office last
week this makes him the 8th Russian
diplomat to die unexpectedly in the last
four months he died quickly he wasn't
sick until the day he died the Kremlin
very quickly called it a heart attack an
initial autopsy was inconclusive medical
examiners saying more tests need to be
done to figure out what really happened
but not only is turqu ins death strange
it's strikingly similar to the death of
Russia's ambassador to India Alexander
kadai 'can't in January 27th also called
a heart attack by the Kremlin and the
death of a Russian diplomat to Greece
Andrei melanin On January 9th the
Kremlin also calling that a heart attack
and then of course there's the death of
Russian diplomat Sergei Kirov of at a
New York consulate on November 8th we
talked about this last week because we
only just learned about it Russian
officials change the story around a few
times about how he died but ended up
calling it a heart attack New York
medical examiner is still not sure how
he died and on December 19th
two Russian diplomats were killed on the
same day in different countries of
course there was Andrei Karlov who was
shot at a photography exhibition in
Turkey by a self-professed
jihadist we covered that story when it
happened it happened on video and then
there was Peter Paul chicag who was shot
dead in Moscow we've also spoken about
Oleg aravindan the man suspected of
helping to create the Trump dossier by
providing some information to former mi6
operative Christopher Steele he was
found dead in the back of his car on
December 26th Russian journalists say
was almost certainly murder
the Kremlin called it a heart attack and
and journalist vladimir karim Orta who
was poisoned for the second time in his
life on february 2nd told you about that
story some weeks ago
that's eight incidents in total since
November involving Russian government
officials or people doing things that
the Russian government may not have
liked a continuation of a long history
of these sorts of deaths over many years
but obviously there's been more lately
than we've seen over the last 5-10 years
whirlwind of conspiracy theories going
around online this is the kind of
conspiracy theory that isn't even really
that much of a conspiracy theory what's
fascinating to me is it's missing from
many of the normal conspiracy websites
they're not talking about this because
to call it a conspiracy theory is almost
not accurate well I mean just because
something's a conspiracy theory does
doesn't mean that it's inherently untrue
right or that it's even wacky I mean it
just hasn't been verified by the
government or the media someone in the
establishment and when the establishment
in this case is a sketchy nation a
sketchy government like Russia I mean
you know it's not like it doesn't make
sense
yeah it's every question is being
brought up about this is sort of the
obvious and logical question you just
you don't have to dig too deep to put
together a hypothesis and a side story
about this I've told you before and I've
read a lot about online influence from
from Russia and disinformation peddlers
and comment trolls if you look at any
popular reddit thread or notable musical
about these Russian deaths or even our
own YouTube clips the comments are
filled with pro-russian comments
skeptical comments saying there's no
record ever of Putin doing anything
sketchy to dissidents it's such obvious
Russian propaganda that flows in and if
you know their techniques you know that
there are teams of people meant to show
up online and leave comments like that
and I mean the latest person killed now
Vitaly Churkin was the ambassador to the
UN for Russia yeah that's our equivalent
of nikki Haley I'm yeses this isn't just
a low-level diplomat and this happened
in New York City absolutely yeah no this
is not some obscure saying happening who
knows where